Lauren made this big deal out of me
having both boys in public and not home
and honestly I'm not worried whatever I
can do it
so today I'm taking the boys to a big
playground for kids okay okay okay
wow what's going on in there
hi there hello good how are you
thank you okay so we take off the shoes
here right there's Cubbies all right
here and then you can leave the stroller
right there okay dear
can I bring the stroller with me yes
please can you bring the stroller in the
thing you'll just have to stay in
between these episodes right here okay
yeah
okay
that sucks though the employee there
tells me that I cannot bring the
stroller inside the area at all okay
Chef you're free buddy you're free
but not two free eight not two free
where am I gonna put us here I can't
carry him all day on my arm is heavy
I know Sharky you want to go up there
but I got Asher I don't know what to do
with them
so what would I do with with the little
ones is there a place to like just a
spot
but there's nowhere to like
leave him right
actually you want to sit in here or it's
too small for no no he's gonna fall over
one can't walk the other one wants to
run around like crazy and I have to keep
an eye on both what am I gonna do now
I don't know what to do this is this
sucks
[Music]